my neighbors next to me are like this
like really old couple who
used to live in l.a so their english is
actually like productive
as well and like and that's good because
like aki isn't like the most proficient
in japanese right yeah
but they obviously know that so every
time they're like me not it was really
weird because like i was walking to my
local supermarket and my neighbor
like walked past and it was really weird
because i was expecting you know like a
very
like traditional japanese like oh yeah
kind of thing
no instead she was like how you going
[Laughter]
like a really like weirdly like
australian british accent as well and
i'm like
i thought you said you lived in l.a that
doesn't sound very los
angeles like yeah yeah and it was just i
was just like oh oh
hi i guess oh because i was fully
expecting to do like the whole bow thing
right but she was just like
sup some old people are real [ __ ]
nice here and they love speaking to you
yeah and then other times like they they
just they want you dead
yeah yeah i mean i guess that's just old
people everywhere with foreigners right
there so no
that's not good but i think japan takes
it to like a whole other level it's just
it seems like one one extreme or the
other yeah it's hard for me to say i
mean
i'm white and grew up in a white place
so i i don't know i mean in england
nobody like nobody
talks to each other or like no like
acknowledges generally talking is
frowned upon
i remember actually the first time i
went to america i was i was in new york
and this was the very first like my very
first experience in america because i'd
like pretty much only been in england
and basically europe and thailand
um so i remember i was standing in the
lift my hotel
and this american there was there was
one other person that left
and she asked me so how how are you
doing today you having a good day
and me as a british person i [ __ ]
freeze up
like i don't know how to act like i'm
like
are you picking a fight with me what the
[ __ ] going on here
what do you want from me are you trying
to sell something because in england you
don't talk to each other you just
every everyone stands there in awkward
silence and doesn't acknowledge each
other
and we go about our day i i had the same
thing in like canada on a bus i was like
17 maybe i was on a bus and the guy like
said like
great weather i'm not doing it yeah
great weather today and i i just
ignored him because i didn't think he
was talking to me
and then he was like not much of a
talker and then i like did like you know
how like out
l stares at uh her light yeah i was like
you're talking to me
because she talks over to me and the
first thing i did was check if there was
someone behind you
i was like yeah in the uk you're it's
just not a thing you don't
have people in public i i i remember
thinking like
oh uh yeah
yes like what do you want like
you want money you're just like a deer
in headlights
you just don't know what to do i know
better now yeah i had the i had the
craziest
[ __ ] like elevators i
i mean i mean it's it's it's not the
extreme situation it's what the guy said
so we've got a [ __ ] in a pumpkin no so
it was my first time in l.a
ever and it was anime expo obviously
because what else would you go to l.a
yeah
um and i was in the hotel uh you know uh
aki was there right now i validate a
story in l.a now
it's always l.a man but you know my
japanese side is always like
if you're just in the elevator by
yourself then you can just be like rowdy
and you know have fun and talk to your
friends and everybody right but the
moment someone you don't know comes in
you gotta like behave right you gotta
like quiet down because you don't wanna
like
so it was me aki and like a few other
people we knew and we were going down
the elevator obviously just chatting it
up whatever
elevator like stops halfway door opens
and this like black guy walks in
don't know him right so immediately i
was like oh [ __ ] someone's
you know coming into the house let's
stop clowning around yeah let's stop
clowning around you know like we don't
want to inconvenience him
he walks in really quietly door closes
starts going down and then he just goes
oh yeah everybody shuts up when the
n-word walks in
and i'm just like i didn't know whether
to say
sorry or like because if i said sorry
then like we would mean that
but i couldn't say anything like i
couldn't even be like
so i was just like eyes darting he's
just being like
what am i supposed to say
so what are you supposed to say to that
in that situation and i was like man
america's [ __ ] terrifying like i'm
i'm taking the escalator from now on
i've never felt more complimented in my
life than when i went into uh an
elevator in l.a
and there was like i think there was a
bunch of women uh there was must been
like five or six of them and they were
like all like mid-40s
i don't know what they were doing and uh
they were just saying something and they
asked me a question and i just responded
and then when they heard my voice they
were like
oh damn where are you from
i was like it's like oh i'm i'm from i'm
from the uk and they're like what do you
do and i was like i do have a voice act
like yeah
yeah you are i was like
i was like oh no i am in danger
but i was so i was so flattered that
like gave me like the confidence boost i
needed that day i was like hell yeah i'm
ready for this panel